i have to ask
uh the the look that you have right now
is it for a roll
uh oh you mean this
yeah no this there's nothing happening
up here anymore that's really what's
going on with that hi
um i i definitely have to ask you what
the hell has
the pandemic been like for you
especially after being
in contagion right oh wow
yeah so eerie how
uh similar the situation in contagion
was to the reality that we've all been
living through
um really scary
um and uh
you know like a lot of people i mean i
guess i've been trying to
use the time well
you know making sure that i'm looking
after myself my emotional health my
mental health
uh physical health um you know
relationships become much more intense
now
because you're always in the company of
your loved ones you really
it's it's hard to get some solitude
but i think all things considered i i've
done very well with it and
you know i hope and pray that we are you
know really going to come up out of the
whatever this is uh soon
i feel like we are um jumping into why i
actually get to talk to you
um what was it about this project uh
besides
uh liam neeson or was it liam neeson
like oh i'm in
well it was primarily it was liam neeson
i'm in um
secondly it was uh
this character goldenrod
and his self-sacrificing nature
his presence as an african-american man
in that part of the world
and in this job
it's not something that i had seen
before not that i had ever watched ice
road truckers but
you know um when we think of uh
these extremely cold weather
environments you know
we think of maybe native people um
[Music]
the fact that there's a native woman in
in this
film uh who's a badass
was something also that i found exciting
and made me want to be a part of it so
uh
you know a combination of all those
things and just
you know i love driving i love the
feeling of the open road i like to be
out there in the world like that
so uh i think that was also a draw for
me
i love watching liam neeson punch people
in the face
as does everybody what is it about liam
neeson punching people in the face that
everyone responds to
you know i think it's more than just his
you know
his physical prowess um it's
his uh you know he is a
he's just a manly man he's like a blokey
bloke
you know uh but he's also very sweet and
very gentle
and very thoughtful um and i think it's
the combination
the juxtaposition of those two things
that make him
you know really really compelling to
what
i actually didn't know much about the
ice road and that entire
part of the world prior to watching this
when when you were doing research and
learning about this what was the one
thing or two things that you took away
like that can't be
real or anything that surprised you no i
i mean
i i i i didn't really do a whole lot of
research i was
i was in the hands of our director and
he had done all of that
um and he kind of laid it out for me
when i when i first got there about
you know the realities of this life
um and i was you know i just i just took
his word for it put my clothes on and
got up in the cab
you know oh i have to ask you what props
or costumes have you taken home or
borrowed from set
throughout your career well i have um
i have my helmet from predators i don't
know if you ever saw that one
oh i did uh i have my glasses
from the matrix and my tie
from the matrix now were you gifted
those or did you borrow them
uh no i was gifted those yeah got it
uh i have a number of hats
from movies that i've done over the
years um that i actually brought to the
production anyway so they were actually
my own
um there's a hat that i used in king of
new york that i still have
uh the hat that i wore in school days i
still have
uh i have a lot of little you know
bits and pieces from the movies i've
made over the years i actually
have show you something really cool
if i can find it i have this
see if you can tell me what this is oh
uh oh that apocalypse now that's my
beret from apocalypse
now yeah yeah so i have some things
that is awesome uh definitely want to
ask you
uh are you coming back for john wick
four i am
yes i am are you going to berlin soon i
should be going to berlin within another
couple of months or so yeah
i love that franchise um what has chad
told you about the story or script
i read the script it's really really
cool
um as much as it's the it's the same
world as the other three films uh
it's just deeper it's much deeper in
terms of
the the code of the assassin
and uh the relationship that he has with
one character in particular who i think
uh mr watanabe is playing
um is really really kind of the heart
and soul of it
i couldn't be more excited um does it
get old people asking you
if you're in the next matrix movie or do
you enjoy no i
i completely understand that that makes
that makes sense i mean it would make
sense that people would ask me that
so it doesn't get old uh i haven't i am
not in the next in the next matrix movie
um and uh you know you'd have to ask
um lonna wachowski why
because i don't have an answer for that
i am disappointed and
and i know you can't say but i'm hoping
you're lying to me because i really do
want you to be in the movie
but you you actually um you have some
other cool stuff coming up that you've
already shot
um my last question for you and the one
that i'm really excited for is the paul
feig movie uh the school for
good and evil which i just wrapped yeah
i really want to know can you say who
you play in that and what what is it
like making that film
i'm playing the school master in that uh
along with uh charlize theron and
kerry washington uh and sophie and
caruso and
sophie wiley um it was great northern
ireland was wonderful we shot you know
in the same studio they shot game of
thrones in
uh they're actually still shooting now
and i expect the movie will be out
sometime in the summer of next year
yeah i'm very excited paul makes good
movies he does he does um on that note i
got to stop i'm just going to say
it's a pleasure to always talk with you
thank you for showing me that apocalypse
now thing and
i'm sure i'll talk to you again soon
thank you